you know like anything is Hannah does
not re 1 answer in a way there were
sequences that were that were technical
look sequences obviously that were
emotional but in a way that was just
hang up the level of the focus of the
film I think for me the purpose of the
phone's always on on Solomon Northup and
attempting to connect as much as i could
to his to his journey and his character
part of that was made out in the in the
biography in his biography and so they
were like clues that is very specific
characteristics but in some of the
things that he endured you know I was
able to then sort of trying in that
never any way I could to how he may have
felt in any given moment and and that
was a real privilege and way you know
the field assented of any kind of
connection to what he went through it is
we were trying to do sequences some of
the sequences as close as we could
possibly do to learn to what he
describes in the in the book so um so
that felt in a way of emotional also
kind of connected to his experience
connected to him which which given a
very different feeling well then yeah
there were times when it was sort of
them emotionally impactful but I think
what we had what we had was a wonderful
crew I mean the support and crew from
him from catering a sadistic for
catering the makeup wardroom you know
here camera department sound department
yeah gaff the gaffer's attrition his
grips and all these boilers came
together and it was almost like was it
was it was our film so with that kind of
support and structure that kind of
camaraderie that kind of family everyone
having a claim on the film at stake in
the film it was such a supportive
atmosphere that in how the actors to
sort of you know go there as it
to do to risk and to try and fail of
course and to feel better and this was
go for it whatever it is what the what
they were trying to go for that there
were no restrictions oh no says
censorship and that environment allow
that to happen and I think we just was
beautiful it was really I don't love in
that set that was beautiful monopoly
open holiday when we go out together
we'll eat together wonderful was a great
through the great time great time making
that money on some levels I mean he
feels like a very definitive the
American story obviously it's a human
story but he's also an American story
how do you approach that to to London
voice you know back on turf now and
you're among friends that you can fief
reading about this is a world story it's
a world store it is not necessarily
American story as such I mean it takes
place in United States but you know this
world but because it has been slavery
and slavery was a world in World
industry as such you know I chose this
back to the story i was looking a full
of looking nose researcher most famous
stories at that time and this that
that's the story that will distract me
so so on the north and story and i said
before i couldn't believe i hadn't come
across this story all this book before I
just couldn't believe it my probably
stupid but then I realized no one else
had so who was were always about the
narrative and the story and wherever it
took place the world didn't really
matter it was leather solid they wanted
to talk about with visual slavery have
many ways felt that there was a kind of
I mean by definition you know there's an
international element to it even
American statement which is slated much
from America so you kind of have there's
you know always been an international
idea with this thing and so and as and
as I learnt about lately that's the way
in which I not bad at you know I learned
about it in terms of Africa turned to
the West Indies to Britain in terms of
America so and South America unique so
so I always had that in my head I felt
like it was a very American story
absolutely but I felt that there was
something correct
an international group of people in a
way even though ninety-seven percent of
people who are involved in this movie
made his living Americans but that there
was an element of something
international about it which I felt
really reflected something about the
International nature of this this event
his world event were you ever worried
that you were going too far were you
worried that maybe you didn't go far
enough and testing some machines if that
was to make the book you know that that
was pretty extreme in the book is bit
extreme but you know my responsibility
of this if I making a film about slavery
or not and I decided I wanted Nikolas
slavery and if you make from that
slavery you have to understand why
people incarcerated in this particular
way in the trading Carter were in
bondage in this kind of way for 400
years this room mental and physical
torture in the way and you know it's a
world event is a huge hole in the
calendar film it's just sometimes a huge
hole in people's minds that they don't
to think about but in order to bring to
the fore because remember in a way I'm
why I as an individual I'm sitting here
today I'm here as individual because
some members of my family went through
slavery fact I managed to be respected
that's what it's a minute can you
explain the audition process how mr.
Ejiofor got the role and the rest of the
cast is worth all of us because so i'll
just do jeito and I mean I knew I knew
each other before and as far as I'm
concerned when the book was only one
acted the play wasn't gentle as I said
before you this is some kind of another
structure of the class there's a dignity
to him which I which I wish I which I
needed which Java needed and they need
to be betrayed in that way because that
was all north of and no shirt l just
just have a great actor and also he's
reminds me of how I believe on tell you
who's to be promoted in some kind of
statute them but then to translate on
screen and that's that in a sentence
that translate on too strong screen and
that's why Germany just as one that one
in a million I see but I just wandered
in in relation to
she relationship then with my passenger
and obviously very close relationship
with each other in what if you can
expand a little bit on how you work
together on how well you work together
and also there were comments I know in
the last few days that's Michael said he
wouldn't turn play the Oscar game and
his top of Oscar nominations with his
own so I just wanted for how you felt
about that and the whole idea of this
Oscar gaming me might go back a well
obviously a while back since 2007 when
my first met him and audition for honda
obviously while they ship has grown
hopefully blossomed into something which
is a you know i value it more than a lot
of things in my life and I battle it
tremendously he's he's an artist he's an
amazing artist to know he's one of her
again it's just a force to be reckoned
with this is some kind of a magic he has
any prints on said I mean he's the kind
of guy that yeah when the user said he
was very quiet he has some kind of
spirit anyway astronomers campaign a nut
or not Omaha I'm not campaigning his
campaign is on his drama Torian that's
Michael Fassbender's oscar campaign he's
the funniest thing that's it got a
question because Steve and I really like
the Eastern music in the film and
handsomer is probably one of the biggest
composers right now is on everything
from pirates to kung fu panda I wondered
why he was chosen to an easy for film
and the process he went through in order
to get the year the fabulous cool that
you going in yeah I just rang him up I
heard that he was oh yeah as you did
become a chat before around hunger
that's why Shane worldwide so he's
writing my daughter too handsome listen
um I'm doing this film there's no money
and Steve I'm destroying the world oh my
god i get to be worried absolutely sir
that movie no strictly it was he was he
was basically making Superman at the
time he says he took me I destroy the
world so but the hands is it possible
think about this idea I'll do it he said
I'll do it that's it that was it so I
did further thank you for coming ok from
there we have a lot of discussion he's
very interesting hazardous a fantastic
guy because everyone seemed to be in my
fantastic but guess what i choose wisely
she is just he's a fantastic guy and we
had like two compensation five hours and
he is based and two other confidential
for about three hours on the phone
seriously and then i came to his studio
and he does this wow it was all that
conversation left a couple of notes so
he has to be a submerged in the
narrative so deeply that he's did he
comes out in another way translates in
him through sound so it's kind of focus
and cross your hands over houses sold
out curious how I just have quick
question for you I Solomon will come
through my striking about Solomon is
that he's not a symbol he's not citing
the character he's an individual how do
you go about developing that kind of
characterization well actually it took
you know it didn't come as easily to you
that easily to me I I when I first read
the script I definitely saw the story of
a man either going through an
extraordinary circumstance I didn't
necessarily see Solomon at this time it
wasn't actually until I read the book
and then went back to the scripture knew
that I suddenly realized you know it was
obvious in a way but I realized that
this is actually the story of of of
Solomon Northup and and and my
responsibility was to civic tell his
story I've seen it initially as a kind
of as telling a story and feel the
responsibility of telling the story
about the slave experience telling one
of the few stories I think one of the
only stories of cinema I'll from inside
the slave experience and so that you
know was the was a bit of a hurdle to me
trying to get my head around how to tell
a story that way through this one person
until of course like a nice thing you
know you wrote a half you don't have to
be like Africa the whole story of
slavery somehow but just a story of
Solomon Northup and and so the book was
then very revealing in terms of his
character and I realized
use his world view and the way that he
approached the world and we approach of
the people away who post these
circumstances was remarkable actually
because if his I try to work out exactly
what his specific characteristics are
but I think that there may need to do is
is extremely reflex of survival and love
of life as well as absence of hatred
that he utilizes that he's able to
continue through the system because he
gets rid of anything that is not useful
to his survival but physically and
mentally and it's an extraordinary
paring down all those elements that
allows him to to navigate this this time
we talked it before about them
uncomfortable moments in the bill like
were there any moments when you first
were reading the book or seeing his grip
that you were really concerned about
going through with and Steve you've
mentioned before about factors doing the
job like were there in the same sort of
way were there any scenes that you were
concerned putting your actors / well
that's me i just thought when I read it
I was just stunned by it you know I just
thought this app as a pc you're gonna
have to just trust it you know as an
actor you're just gonna have to just
slip down the rabbit hole and see what
happens you know because you know
there's no rooms just no way of telling
the story you know and I and it's not
like I wasn't aware of of Steve and his
films you know min so I you know you
know so you know I knew that he would go
to all the places that you'd have to go
to and I'm like and that's what I wanted
you know to tell this story I just
thought that that's the only way I miss
would come back something were to me
earlier it's the only be peak and where
you can't tell a story about slavery
unless you tell it you know that's it
and and so you're gonna have to you know
it's like you know people talk about
sort of violence and stuff but it's sort
of weird to me because it's a strange
handicap if you're not if you can't talk
about violence in a film about slavery
you're not going to do justice to any
other people involved you're not saying
I'm going to do justice to Solomon
Northup and what
went through you know it's you know it's
like doing that about the second world
war or something because she'd anybody
you know it's not you can't tell these
stories without these major parts of
what they are and I and I read that and
I read and I read into that you know I
read into the into the script that was
obviously going to be this kind of these
these struggles that he went through and
then I was I wanted to embrace that I
was excited about I wanted to ask Steve
now that he has done such good movies
was it difficult to get the money from
American industry is a black man i think
i was very prime dated practically
behind it we're very supportive and Brad
Pitt of course of petrol supportive I
had great people helping fox searchlight
on will show producer and also Brad Brad
Weston and those are the group of people
who came to go put the demonic isn't
even in development needed me so that
that that was great and if they believe
in the subject more importantly so it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't as difficult
as maybe people many people thought
month when you approach this role in
your mind how did you go about ensuring
the audience stayed attached and engage
with your character when essentially
he's becoming more introverted and
throughout that hardship until the final
scenes um I think because when I you
know I had a very when I first read this
new plan when I first read the book I
had a very immersive experience with it
which was in a way that I just felt like
I was reading like I was observing
something just reading book description
and buy at a certain point I don't even
know exactly when that is it was like I
was inside the experience with it you
know so the sudden things would say
happened to him or whatever and I would
feel like I was just very emotionally
connected and I felt like there's
something about it that is very
immersive but I thought very immediately
immersive because
suppose in a way we can all relate to
that you can all kind of easily
understand some of the summer that the
sense of just being ripped away from
everything that you hold dear and then
putting this kind of like Alice in
Wonderland slip down rabbit hole into
this kind of bizarre universe that he's
sort of walking you through and I felt
that that the power of that could be
conveyed in any medium I think that's
why it's such a strong book you know and
why such a strong screenplays because
actually what Simon is relating is
something that people can quickly get on
board with quite quickly understand you
know so I didn't I wasn't worried about
that anyway and so I didn't feel like it
was my job to to try and carry buddy
anybody's through which I thought might
have been interrupting I just felt like
if I kept close to Solomon and told his
story but I kind of trusted in the
narrative of course the president's team
you know Anna and I thought that was the
way that this that people would connect